allora ragazzi oggi è l'ultima lezione
prima dell'esame di domani lezione
fondamentale ripeto fondamentale perché
se non capite quello che spiego oggi
molto probabilmente non mi possa vedere
esame domani quindi aprite le orecchie e
iniziamo su studenti online seconda
parte iscriviti al canale per non
perdere neanche un video che mi dice
prove mente dove eravamo arrivati
rubelli brasile dico io però resto tutto
però prima possa andare in bagno perché
ciò ho le mie cose che ti devo dire vai
garay regalami una gioia no cioè profilo
giuridico long però cioè se mi dicevo
carino un solo argomento dove eravamo
arrivati più che c'è un ottimo olandesi
ma abbia verona vicenza di non farti
vedere che non interessa nessuno vederti
in questo momento è il secondo
dell'accesso ciò perché non dovrei farlo
ma perché sei successo garay perché sei
successo a defecare a google.com mi
avete visto mi mini che figura di merda
molto distintamente ripuliva mi
aspettavo e stocco di marzia dai
racconta mito si prof
tutto bene
sa un po di sbatti sarà non vederle tipo
a scuola prima era più facile broccolare
adesso di like di marce diceva racconta
di dove siamo arrivati non la tua vita
privata non me ne frega niente problemi
ma quanto sei stata in bagno ma io ma io
davvero ma come devo fare con voi
ragazzi senti rubelli pane mi guardava
mente di un argomento a piacere anzi
quadro di una poesia una poesia che ti
ha colpito tra quelle studiate e non lo
so dimmi qualcosa sì però finder e io
vidi una poesia anche rientro molto
commoventi e si chiama siamo suoi
acquisì siamo soli a parte il conio
a parte il quadro quello reanto di
tumore o la camicia stadi fumo antico
trono mian siamo attaccati nuovi manchi
ea dirgli come in archi perché l'uomo
tantissimo
bella bella questa dichiarazione d'amore
2.0 posso sapere il nome del poeta ma
chi ne saprò se si chiama tipo da stupri
amia supremi anche amy e stupì e vabbè
approfondirò le sue opere di marzio
torniamo da te ma cosa è successo tv chi
vedo per la prima volta vestito ma è un
miracolo ragazzi si prof
ma la maglietta è l'unica cosa che
indosso ma che maiale di marzo ma che
schifo
guarda se fossimo a scuola di aver già
sbattuto fuori ma anche per stavolta
devo chiudere un occhio
gli anelli ti prego almeno tu sì pro se
non le dispiace vorrei presentarle un
power point fatto da me personalmente in
cui riassume poi collego fra di loro le
varie opere analizzati in questi mesi
finalmente un alunno con la maiuscola
delizia mi vianelli delizia mi si allora
vorrei partire prima di tutto con le
novelle di verga raccolta di novelle
scritte da giovanni verga la suite tante
ed è lì ma cos'è questo rumore sì
parliamo infatti di amore che
e le opere
gli anelli c'è rumore non si sente
niente sì esatto esatto
detto questo assente
pazzo interpretazione novi anelli non è
capito non sentiamo di a tua mamma di
spendere l'aspirapolvere
oddio la sfida polvere vero la prima di
spedirla mamma mamma
e niente anche oggi abbiamo sprecato
un'ottima occasione per imparare
qualcosa di nuovo ma io ve lo giuro e
dalla prossima volta chi non è preparato
viene sospeso perché veramente non ne
posso più
e voi che state guardando il video
innanzitutto studiati più di loro e poi
iscrivetevi a questo benedetto canale
attivate tutte le notifiche cliccate la
campanella commentate mettetela insomma
c'è un po di impegno ragazzi
[Musica]